some of this was done yesterday but i
think more of it um we could do more
from our ends on this front uh but to
answer your direct question uh weija um
this is the that's the end of the fiscal
year and what our objective here was was
to to provide a long enough uh set of
funding requests or a
funding request that would meet
that would mean we wouldn't have to come
back in a month or six weeks right um to
ensure that there was planning that was
possible through the us military and
through our european partners and the
ukrainians as well now some of this
funding for example the six billion of
this uh of this 20 billion dollars of
the security assistance component is for
the ukraine security assistance
initiative which is basically direct
support for ukraine to purchase its own
weapons uh from the defense you know
defense contra you know the defense
industry here in the united states um
they could not even intake um you know
billions and billions and billions of
weapons and security assistance in this
moment so that is likely going to be
longer term because if they place an
order for specific weapons sometimes
that takes months to produce it's just
meant to provide security assistance so
they can plan for what they need over
the long term and make those orders
directly which is what that portion of
the uh of the funding provides for the
other portions of the funding so 5.4
billion is in drawdown so that as you're
very familiar with that because that was
a large chunk of what we we requested
and have implemented in our last package
and that basically allows the united
states to uh when we provide weapons or
give weapons uh to the ukrainians to
have the funding to backfill
those needs and order those weapons so
we can backfill them here and make sure
we have what we need here in the united
states um 2.4 billion was to purchase
high demand weapons for the united
states build additional critical war
reserves and increase intelligence and
other defense support and then four
billion is in state foreign military
financing which is not just for ukraine
that's for a range of countries it's fmf
funding that arrange that will be
applicable to a range of countries and
what their needs are and finally 2.6
billion is to continue supporting u.s
troop deployments in nato territory so
as you know we had 80 about 80 000 and
now we're up to a hundred thousand and
we're also of course um you know
providing support uh to a range of our
nato allies and partners in the region
and that helps support that includes u.s
troop transportation special pay medical
support so that's kind of the breakdown
of what it is but some of that would
certainly go beyond it was just meant to
be a request that accounts for the
fiscal year
and then um
turning to covid i know you've talked
before about protocols in place to
protect the president
but given
what kate bettingfield tweeted this
morning i wonder
is part of the protocol to make sure the
president never has any close contacts
well the way we determine we do take
additional steps and some of those are
additional precautions that go beyond
even what the cdc recommends right so if
we are in a meeting with the president
i've noted before we you always are
tested
we often wear masks almost always wear
masks in those meetings
we are try to socially distance whenever
possible and the way the cdc defines and
the
close contact uh is 15 minutes at a
certain close proximity so we try to
follow those guidelines and take
additional steps of course as out of an
effort to protect the president
those who are in a confined space with
the president wear masks and are six
feet apart from him that's an effort we
make exactly right and then just quickly
on the
vaccines for children yeah because the
fda's announced a couple potential dates
for when they might start reviewing in
june yeah when the green light is given
assuming it will be is there enough
supply
already on hand
to
start giving these young children
their first doses right away the supply
of both the vaccine and files materials
et cetera um my understanding which is
that there is i will quadruple check
that and make sure for you uh but we
have been planning for the possibility
of approval for vaccines for children
under five for some time now um and we
like to plan ahead thanks jen go ahead
thank you jen um the mayor of eagle pass
told my colleague down at the border
today and mayor
is a democrat by the way that the order
is not being effectively managed and
asked the president to come and see it
does the president have any plans to go
to the floor
i don't have any plans to preview at
this point in time certainly we're open
to it but no plans to preview is it
something he would consider doing before
the summit of the americas where he's
set to meet with the leaders of central
and south america see the situation
firsthand before having that robust
conversation well he's meeting with
leaders of countries that he's traveled
to many times and certainly is very
familiar with the issues that will be
discussed which is addressing root
causes coordinating whether it's
on the economic front or security front
um and that's an initiative he led
during the when he was vice president so
he's very familiar with those issues on
the uh economy austin
the former uh chair of the council of
economic advisors
administration said that he felt that
the president yesterday in his comments
about the gdp report was potentially
underplaying the risks of a recession
and he pointed to
geopolitical conditions with ukraine
with russia cutting off gas to europe
and also gdp shrinking saying that
people should be nervous how do you
respond to that well i have a great deal
of respect for austin goldsby he's a
former colleague and so does the
president um but what we look at is a
range of
economic data including economic data
that was in the gdp numbers yesterday
which i did some explaining of yesterday
but some of the data that was in there
are show very encouraging signs that
economists look at independent many
independent economists monitor closely
american consumer spending business
investment residential investment
all up the decrease as it relates to
exports is largely because our economy
is stronger than many economies around
the world and the inventory numbers
which is kind of the number that went
down that brought it down is in large a
large
in large part because the fourth quarter
inventory numbers were the highest in
history and these numbers are drawn are
done as a comparison from quarter to
quarter so i think we felt it was
important to explain the data and what
it means we continue to monitor economic
data it's important to note that um the
the the some some important components
of it are uh we created more jobs last
year than any job in american history
we're at a low a very low unemployment
rate and while costs are high and
inflation is not where we want it to be
the federal reserve continues to project
that will come down by the end of the
year so our economist and our economic
team continues to
feel confident in the strength of the
economy even as we monitor a range of
data jennifer granholm said something
though that was interesting about
inflation coming down
she said some economists are suggesting
inflation is going to level off a bit
but it's just so hard to know because we
don't know what's going to happen on the
war on this
so
she's seeming to also allude to
geopolitical conditions that might not
result in these projections coming to
fruition well the federal reserve makes
the official projections right for the
government what i will note and i think
maybe she was referring to is even the
new economic data we saw today um energy
accounted for 61
of the reasoning for the increase in in
the inflation numbers and we know that
because of putin's unprovoked invasion
in ukraine uh that it's driving uh food
costs but also energy costs and that is
a huge driver so that's why the
president is taking a range of steps the
historic release from the strategic
petroleum reserve even the steps
certainly smaller as it relates to e15
today to work to really target and focus
on energy prices and costs and i have
just a couple questions on the
disinformation board sure
yesterday you had told me that you were
not familiar with nina jankowicz i'm
wondering if you're more information on
her today also secretary america said
that he was not familiar with statements
that she had made surrounding the hunter
biden laptop and i'm just wondering
how how is she hired if you in the white
house are not familiar with her if mjork
is not familiar with her statements
what's the process for
um putting her into a position like this
who's in charge of her well let me give
you a sense of who she is she's an
expert on online disinformation she was
formerly in the wilson center's
disinformation she was formerly a
disinformation fellow at the wilson
center she's testified before congress
as well as the united kingdom and
european parliaments advise a ukrainian
foreign minister particularly relevant
in this moment under the auspices of a
fulbright public policy fellowship and
overseeing russia and belarus programs
at the national democratic institute any
hiring decisions are up to the
department of homeland security but this
is a person with extensive
qualifications
what i will tell you about the board and
what the board is doing this is a
continuation of work that began at the
department of homeland security in 2020
under former president trump
is it though
i guess you can use describe what her
job is going to be because there's been
some um tick tocks that she has put out
um and it seems like rather than you
know calling balls and strikes on this
you know story is false and this story
and here's the truth on it um one line
stood out to me uh they're laundering
disinfo we should really take note and
not support their lies with our wallets
or vote so here's what the board is
going to do which i think is a
particular interest again a continuation
of the work of the former president so
for anyone who's critical of it i don't
i didn't hear them being critical of the
work under the former president which is
just interesting to note contextually
but in the fact sheet that they put out
what they noted yesterday what they
noted in there is that this is meant to
uh won the first bullet was about
protecting privacy civil rights and
civil liberties and the first amendment
they said the primary mission is to
establish best practices to to to ensure
that efforts to understand and respond
to disinformation are done in ways that
protect privacy civil rights and civil
liberties i'd also note that the first
example they gave
about what they're going to do is uh is
support the department of homeland
security's work ongoing work back to the
former administration on to address how
and understand how misinformation spread
by human smugglers that prey on
vulnerable populations attempting to
migrate to the united states there's no
question everybody that bipartisan
support for that to address
disinformation that's going that's
helping smugglers uh
uh pushing helping people
migrate or providing false information
uh prompting people to migrate um so and
this is also work um
that is helping to address unauthorized
uh terrorism other threats and see how
disinformation and misinformation is
being pushed uh to lead uh to increase
those so that's all work we we think is
work that's been ongoing for some time
this is the form it's taking and there's
a fact sheet that details the specifics
of it you just outline a lot of you know
efforts that sound very worthy but
you've got someone from the home part of
homeland security telling people how
they should vote how do you
explain that to critics who say that
doesn't sound right to me uh this is an
individual who'll oversee overseeing the
work of that board personnel decisions
are up to the department of homeland
security i just outlined the extensive
history and background this individual
has but i think what's important to note
here is what the board is doing which is
continuing what is important
disinformation related work that began
under the former administration go ahead
i want to ask you about some of the
concerns that democrats are expressing
about title 32 if it is in fact lifted
and these are some quotes
that were in politico today maggie
hassan says what i didn't hear was
specifics about numbers and deployment
and really meeting the need at the
border
senator catherine cortez cortez masto
said she still hasn't seen a
comprehensive plan and senator mark
kelly has said there's having things on
a piece of paper and then what is going
on in the southern border and there's a
huge disconnect what is the
administration doing to address those
concerns and that criticism that there
may be a plan on paper but they
certainly haven't seen it at the border
yet well first there's an extensive plan
on paper that includes a six pillar
approach to planning for and preparing
for the lifting of title 42 including
surging resources personnel
transportation medical support
facilities to support border operations
it also includes enhancing cpp
processing efficiency and moving with
deliberate speed to mitigate potential
overcrowding at border patrol stations
something in anticipation they are
preparing for the possibility of it also
includes administering consequences for
unlawful entry that's pillar three
includes number four is bolstering the
capacity of non-governmental
organizations who've been important
partners to us as we're working to
implement to receive non-citizens after
they've been processed it also includes
targeting disrupting the transnational
criminal organizations and finally
deterring irregular migration what it is
not and this is where we absolutely of
course agree with these members and
others is an immigration reform plan and
that is something that we strongly
support this is a reminder of the need
for how outdated it is how broken the
system is but title 42 has never been an
immigration plan how soon
will the plan that you just laid out
actually go into effect understanding
that it may take some time yeah how soon
will people actually feel the real
impact so that as senator kelly is
saying this discount connect doesn't
exist so that there's actual proof that
it's taking place well the title 42
lifts on may 23rd um it doesn't lift
nothing happens until i would point to
the apartment like homeland security for
the implementation plan but i think
that's what's important to note here we
haven't seen uh you know the impacts of
the lifting surges because it hasn't
happened yet i'd also note that
secretary mayor has testified i believe
before four committees over the last two
days about exactly this
in order to answer their questions and
i'm sure he's happy to have continued
conversations concerned is the president
that these members of his own party who
are facing tough reelection
as you know
have these serious concerns and and
clearly are expressing
fears that it might impact them
politically might impact their chances
for reelection well without speaking to
the politics i would say kristin i mean
the president shares the concern about
the lack of a a workable immigration
system and that impacts
many of the border state
leaders quite a bit of course because
there isn't an effective asylum
processing system because we don't have
smart security we spent years investing
in a faulty border wall that was never
going to
be an effective mechanism
he shares their concerns about that and
he recognizes and agrees with that how
would you characterize how committed he
is
understanding that an appeal if it comes
to that is not in his hands
would he want to see this fight go all
the way to the supreme court
i'm certainly not going to get ahead of
a legal process i will note uh and mary
i think mary ellen asked about this
yesterday uh so let me in terms of where
things stand um um
so
right now what we saw yesterday is that
the district record presiding over one
of the challenges to the title 42
rescission order officially entered
finally officially entered because they
just done it verbally a temporary
restraining order what that basically
means is they're saying we can't lift
title 42 before may 23rd that has not
been our plan to date as you know uh
what is next is there's going to be a
hearing on arizona's preliminary
injunction motion that's scheduled to
take place on may 13th so any decision
about what's next of course would happen
from the department of justice but
wouldn't happen after until after that
what i would note is that the judge has
indicated he will rule unfavorably
towards the administration at this time
but we don't know and we don't
officially know we won't know until he
makes a ruling and then department of
justice would make any decision about
legal action one quickly on the
supplemental if i might there's
obviously a divide over whether to link
it to poker funding which we talked
about a little bit here yesterday but
given that there is this divide and
given the urgency that we are hearing
from president zelinski and others on
the ground in ukraine for this eighth
why not just say let's de-link
these two bills and move forward with
ukrainian and get it done as quickly as
possible well kristin i would note that
the president feels that both are urgent
both are emergencies
of course we know there's an urgency in
getting additional assistance we know we
have a few more weeks depending on how
the final military drawdown is spent out
but on terms of covid what we are doing
right now is we are preventing the
united states from being able to plan
and purchase ahead so for example if
there's a better booster which there may
be because science is amazing one day
right if there's a better vaccine we
can't make purchases ahead of doing that
that is what we have done to date that
is why we've been so prepared it also
makes it so that we can't purchase
every shelled treatments that helps
immunocompromise we can't make
additional purchases of a range of the
treatments we know are effective and
make sure that we can say to every
american we'll get you a mass we'll get
you a test we'll get you a free vaccine
so the president feels that is also
incredibly urgent
but do you have a reaction to the report
that the fbi
last year potentially searched millions
of americans uh data and secondly is the
president briefed on that does he have
any reaction in himself i have not
spoken with the president about this um
i can get you more details about this
after the briefing my understanding is
that some of this was about uh
researching and doing an investigation
into potential hacking um and uh and so
but i will get you more from the fbi
after this thanks for the question go
ahead yeah e-15 fuel is slightly less
energy dense than uh what we would
consider typical gasoline so americans
might need to fill up just a little bit
more frequently so how much does the
administration really think that this
move will affect americans wallets and
does the white house believe the
president has exhausted his authority on
what he can do related to gas prices or
are there more options still being
considered i mean on the second question
we're always going to look for more
options i mean we saw and i talked about
this a little bit earlier even as it
relates to the recent the the inflation
data that came out today uh we know that
61 of that is driven by the price by
energy cost by putin's invasion into
ukraine and we need to continue to take
every step we can whether that's working
with congress considering what
authorities we have continuing to ensure
we take steps to
make sure the supply meets the demand
out there um you know the estimates have
been it saves americans about 10 cents a
gallon
and you know that to the president and
to us felt like a reason to do it um and
because without taking the step for the
waiver it basically would just be an
option of additional supply that is a
little bit less expensive that wouldn't
be available in these 2000 gas stations
we're not saying that this is like the
silver bullet it's not it's just a step
that we felt would help ease the um ease
the burden for americans who go to those
gas stations and then with covid on uh
as we are talking about um as the white
house is
pushing congress to pass for more
funding
the administration released a plan at
least for now to transition the burden
of paying for covered drugs and vaccines
to the private sector kind of like has
been done with tests so that insurance
companies have time to negotiate
well um there's a range of steps
happening at the same time but i will
tell you that what we want to continue
to be able to do is to provide these
treatments for free that's the objective
that's the reason for this request for
funding
but also the request for funding is
enabling the united states to be able to
purchase ahead and bulk supply a lot of
these treatments or um you know vaccines
so that we can make when they are ready
we can make those available to treatment
centers and hospitals around the country
good okay thanks um i know you said that
you didn't get an extensive freedom yet
of the conversation with the mexican
president and there'll be a written
readout at some point yes dad but you
yeah you know what happened uh did the
president make any headway in getting
mexico to take the harder line on russia
and should we expect them to join the
global coalition in imposing sanctions
now well i would note obviously the
mexican government can speak for
themselves on any intentions they may or
may not have
they have spoken out
against russia's invasion of ukraine so
i would note that we will always
encourage any leaders to take additional
steps to support the ukrainians and
stand up in a range of ways against uh
the uh invasion of ukraine by russia um
but in terms of any steps they would
take
regardless of the conversation we would
let them speak for themselves on that
front go ahead as has uh the reticence
by the mexican government
impacted the u.s mexico relationship in
any way when it comes to sanctions well
again i would note they have spoken out
against
russia's invasion of ukraine we know
different countries are going to take
different steps
some have taken them quickly some took
longer to take them and we know
different countries will have different
approaches to every step whether it's
sanctions assistance they can provide we
understand that uh we have an important
uh strong relationship with mexico one
that the call today was set up in order
to really focus the conversation on
migration and addressing root causes in
advance of the summit of the americas so
that was really the majority of the
conversation i'm sorry i didn't mean to
miss you go ahead no worries uh thank
you uh so pentecost secretary john kirby
was asked this afternoon if he believed
that vladimir putin was a rational actor
and he responded saying i can't talk to
his psychology but i think we can all
speak to his depravity you know he later
apologized for his emotions there but
i'm curious are these sentiments also
shared by the president
well i think you've heard the president
call him a war criminal
so i don't think the president
thinks of president putin as somebody
who is a model in the world
he feels he's he views him as a pariah
and somebody who is guilty of war crimes
and of genocide so i think the
president's comments speak for itself
and then also piggybacking on uh
kristen's last question if if congress
doesn't pass supplemental aid to ukraine
or it's delayed
how much longer can we keep the current
pace in in supporting them
well there's a range of ways we're
supporting them right so this is why i
felt it was important to outline in more
detail than i did yesterday sometimes
you go back and you say i need more
information i um but that's what we did
here but um we know we there's 250
million left right from uh the security
package we know that we were giving up
we were at a very rapid pace of
providing assistance for several weeks
that was strategic because we wanted to
front load that knowing that as russia
repositioned their approach to the war
the needs for the ukrainians were
different because it was going to be a
longer more drawn out war that was more
kind of on the ground so we
strategically front loaded a lot of the
security assistance but there is not we
expect a couple more weeks this
assistance could be i don't have the
plans from the department of defense on
exactly how they will how they will roll
that out i also noted that um
the vast vast majority of our economic
assistance has also been exhausted
obviously many of those many of those
needs are long term
some of the funding about three billion
of it was for operating needs of the
department of defense some of those are
still being spent out and are part of
their budget not direct assistance of
course and then there are still there is
still funds in the humanitarian
assistance bucket but that doesn't meet
all of the needs of course that the
ukrainians have so this is why there's
an urgency to moving forward and lastly
i understand that uh the circumstances
surrounding mr cancel staff are still
coming to light but does the president
have any plans to to talk with his
relatives
it's a great question and what i tried
to convey perhaps not articulately is
that it has not gone through the proper
channels that typically are the state
department defense department etc
usually the state department likely in
this case um and if there is a call to
read out i will certainly let all of you
know um go ahead i can do like a few
more i think go ahead
so it sounds like the president is still
planning to attend the white house
correspondents there
in past when he's been exposed in large
events the white house has noted that
there might be an increase in his
testing following those are there any
plans to change the president's testing
procedures following these big events
that he's been attending like the dinner
and
the two memorial services he attended
the testing protocol is determined by
his doctor he was tested yesterday and
he tested negative but i don't have
anything to predict in terms of the
future i noted this the other day but i
think that's important for your question
here is that the president we made a
decision it was important to him to
attend the dinner to honor the work of
journalists all of you many of your
colleagues around the world something
the former president uh didn't do uh but
uh we also took additional steps he's
not attending the dinner portion he's
coming for the program so and he will
likely wear a mask when he's not
speaking obviously he'll speak and so
he'll be there for about an hour or 90
minutes i guess depending on how long
trevor noah speaks and others speak in
the program um but we took that
additional step as well and then he's of
course sitting on the dice um up in the
front so the interaction he's not
attending uh any of the receptions or
anything along those lines either on the
remarks uh
the president has been a guest on
several late night shows has he uh
consulted any of those host comedians
brought in any outside help on his
speech can you kind of bring us in the
room on how he's approaching this as
someone who has attended uh several of
these dinners and seen them playing has
i would tell you the president has a
very good sense of humor and is working
hard on his own speech
the administration has not said how long
they expect the war in ukraine to last
and that's understandable because no one
knows what the future will hold
um but the administration and then also
in this room yesterday the
administration has declined to say how
much the united states is prepared to
spend long term
or to give a real definition of what a
victory in the war in ukraine would look
like so my question is how long does
president biden the same president who
got us out of afghanistan because he
said it was a costly and unwinnable
quagmire
how long does he expect the american
people to back this war when they don't
know
how long it will last
how much it will cost or what the
ultimate um definition of victory
actually is
well
i mean let me just reiterate something
the president has said from the
beginning i will get to your point but
this i will get to your questions i
promise um
that combating russian aggression has
costs leaving it unchecked would be even
more costly allowing russia to run
rampant around europe beyond ukraine
which is what president putin outlined
in his speech right before he invaded
would be incredibly costly to the world
and to the united states
we calculate that as well right now i
know uh let me i will get there i
promise i know you're raising your hand
you asked me a few questions i'm gonna
get there
right now the importance of this package
to the president is because every day
ukrainians pay the price of freedom in
their lives and he feels providing them
with arms and foods is the right thing
to do and trying to plan for and i noted
that some components of this package are
not limited it's not that the spending
will end at five months it's just
allowing the ability for us the
ukrainians and the europeans to plan
over the long term in fact much of the
security assistance will be much longer
than that the reason it's difficult to
define what winning is is because
obviously our our view continues to be
that an end will be through a diplomatic
process and a diplomatic conversation
the ukrainians are the ones to determine
what the outcome of that will look like
not for us to determine on their behalf
should we expect a line item
appropriation for military aid ukraine
for the next five ten fifteen years i
mean is this open-ended we of course
want the war to end as quickly as
possible and president putin could do
that tomorrow uh but right now we're
making a decision about what we're
advocating for is trying to support and
have the backs of an incredibly brave
country and their people who are
kicked out of their homes fighting an
aggressive dictator in his military
lacking food lacking economic assistance
and preventing putin from rampaging
through europe which by the way would be
much more expensive than what we're
talking about here
so the united states definition of what
success or victory looks like in the
region is contingent on how long
ukrainians are willing to combat the
russians and whether or not they want to
you know fight them and force them to
the negotiation table or push them out
of you know their borders that's up to
them but it works not exactly what i
said what i will say is that what
president putin defined as his own
version of winning and victory from the
beginning was um taking over ukraine
their sovereignty their territorial
integrity obviously he's already failed
at that right so in that sense they are
already defeating putin's effort to
envelop them into russia but this is an
ongoing war we know that we know that
diplomacy and having a discussion and
negotiation is the way to get an end to
it our effort and our focus is on
strengthening them at the negotiating
table and that's the role that we feel
that we can play i'm going to have to
wrap this up asthma go ahead and mark
you oh announcement just you asked me a
question yesterday about a credit that
is not possible
okay good but for others yes um so there
have been reports that eu countries are
looking to approve a fees uh embargo on
russian oil as obvious next week yeah
that would have happened it would be
huge and i'm curious how the white house
is coordinating with the wellness sure
so one of the steps that the president
took uh last month was to start this
task force with the europeans i mean we
took steps before that right to work
with a range of countries
in asia and around the world to provide
additional supply lng supply where they
had access japan for example did that to
provide excess lng supply because they
had the ability to do that to the
europeans in anticipation that russia
could
weaponize energy as we've seen president
putin do there was a meeting of this
task force yesterday to continue that
coordination have that discussion and
we're just looking for ways that we can
help them address these needs that we
long anticipated
thank you everyone
1